the leaders of Russia and belarusa
meeting for the first time since the
short-lived Mutiny by the Wagner
mercenary group last month the meeting
comes amid Rising tensions with Poland
and Moscow has warned that any
aggression against its Ally Belarus
would be considered an attack on Russia
now before we go to our guest on this
listen to the Belarusian leader
Alexander lukashenka he made some
controversial comments about the Wagner
group
the Wagner Fighters have become a
concern they're asking to let them go
west I'm asking them why would you do
that we're quietly keeping tabs on them
and they say we just want to you know go
on a trip to Warsaw and jeshov jeshoff
triggers them because when they fought
in bakmut they knew where the Western
military hardware was coming from so
they have this feeling that zeshov is a
problem of course I'm keeping them in
central Belarus like we agreed and I
wouldn't want to redeploy them there as
they're in this bad mood
Pavel felgenhauer's defense and Military
analyst you're joining us from Moscow
today Pavo thanks for coming on the
program give me your read on what you
just heard
uh well I would say this is classical
Alexander rukashenka he for many years
decades even was playing between kind of
Russia and the West against each other
getting perks from all sides in the last
several years that's not working at all
his situations with the Western totally
severed he depends fully on Russia on
Moscow doesn't like it
and now he's trying to play A ranked
game with West and East at the same time
using the Wagner group kind of saying
that these guys were ready to begin
World War III by invading Poe and
martial and Warsaw and I'm the only
person who can hold them back
but you have to pay me
and most likely he's saying that and
only to the west but also to President
Vladimir Putin because really no one
wants right now uh escalation to a no
European War that's going to go nuclear
okay well that's what I wanted to ask
you do you honestly believe that Wagner
would could go into Poland because
that's that's a whole different ball
game if they do that if you're attacking
Poland you're attacking NATO strongest
military Alliance in the world
well of course they can't they battle
hardened Veterans of Bahamut they know
how to fight but going against NATO and
it's Superior Air Forces uh that can
actually devastate anything in Belarus
easily and can quickly move into action
with hundreds maybe even a thousand
warplanes uh that would be Toto is
but playing a racket is a different
thing and provocations on the borders
also could happen they did happen in
recent years when lukashenka was
encouraging refugees from the Middle
East from Afghanistan to cross into
Poland causing problems there so again
to put pressure on the west basically
playing a racket game because the
gardeners now are in Belarus they're
good Fighters but they are expensive
Fighters and bukashenko wants to be paid
and he says they're not on the Polish
border right now per se they said in
central Belarus which is mogulov region
and that's much closer to smaleskin and
the road that's Russian big city on the
border and the road from swanesque to
Moscow so he's saying put the Putin also
you should kind of if I'm custodian the
Wagner's don't cause trouble
major trouble you should all guys pay me
for doing the job of being their
custodian
so this is how I read this situation
okay that that was not my initial read
of this so what you're telling us is
this is actually not really that much of
a threat to Nato because Wagner doesn't
intend to go into Poland you're telling
us this is a this is a gentle or not so
gentle nudge
on Vladimir Putin
oh yes and that's what uh is playing and
both all sides is trying to do that
because seeing these These are terrible
people they can do create a kind of
world war out of nothing uh and I can
only hold them connect only person there
to control them and but I need money to
do that to keep them happy you should
pay me it's kind of rather primitive but
ukashenka style a political racket but
of course
provocations on the right on the the
Polish border are possible the polls
move to brigades and the polls are to
abolish authorities are talking about
the threat coming from Wagner because
the Polish government will actually also
would like to see more uh threatening
noise coming from the border they would
also want the Americans to move
additional troops from the continental
United States like a whole tank division
they were inviting them to come and have
a permanent base in Poland and so
they're also would be ready to
exaggerate the threat and Moscow and
minsker talking about the polls that
they can move and do for their forces
and to Ukraine so there's a lot of talk
there to magnify the threat on this part
of the world okay the possibility of a
terrible escalation really interesting
could be a chess game according to you
that serves multiple interests Pavel
felgan Howard defense and Military
analyst thank you for coming on the
program
thank you